as someone who runs a company I've been
told that it is my job to occasionally
have performance reviews and I've asked
for some assistance from my script
supervisor this is Danielle Weisberg
hello Danielle you are a script
supervisor are you not no what are you
the monologue assistant Oh what does
script supervisor do that's Susie
who Susie
[Music]
[Music]
what is your name please
Megan what is your title in position I'm
a photographer you're a photographer
yeah the show needs a photographer yeah
all right you seem defensive are you a
little bit why because you're
questioning my position on the show make
it in no way do I want you to feel
nervous about this this is just to
decide whether or not you should be
fired or not what is your height five
seven five seven what is your gender
female hey I have to fire three
employees today it's just the way it is
this is the staff and crew of Conan
would you please identify it the three
people you think should go who's that
Jordan claims George Tracy okay I took
no time at all maybe if you have any
complaints from me about the way that I
run the show
are there any personal quirks that I
have that make you uncomfortable
no I've been in the habit last few years
of walking up behind women and massaging
their shoulders the same daddy's home
inappropriate okay normally this is the
point where I would give you an eight
ten percent raise not really going to do
that you are getting a great job pin
and I'd like you to wear that here at
the show and at home
Matthew creamer
you I know this is your performance
review and what's your position here in
show productions their production stuff
what does that mean describe what you do
I do a lot of things a lot of logistics
ideal love with the Warner Brothers lot
I help with scouting locations for
remote doesn't me that when someone says
I do a lot of things it's to cover the
fact that they do very little I don't
disagree with that assessment okay
disagreeing with hosts of show duty
complaints about the work environment
here it's very much unlike any other
business environment have you ever seen
me do anything that you thought was
unprofessional but squeaky chair over
there
is that you Craven sorry abused me how I
used you what have I done to you
I believe recently I was choked I choked
him and then you pushed me so what do
you think when I walk up to you in the
hallway and I jump on you and start
choking you I think it's a release valve
and I think it's an actual release no
you said no now that you said release
you it's a relief I it's a sexual
release no but now that you're saying
that now I'm concerned and maybe it is
okay does that bother you is that okay
that's how I get my sexual thrill by
jokingly doesn't bother me so you're
okay with it bother other people you're
okay with me choking you if it gives me
sexual pleasure go just say just sign
and also what say there's a fire do you
think you're strong enough to carry me
out of this building if I run conscious
I believe I could get you out
this is me I'm choking you been smoke
fills right the room
[Music]
what's your name please my name is Brad
Brad I'm the photo researcher what does
a photo researcher do I find and license
all the still images that use on the
show let's say we needed a photo of Al
Roker how long would it take you to get
a photo about Roker like 20 seconds
maybe what about Al Roker wearing
pajamas okay not bad you didn't find out
real cream pajamas but you did find him
in a gingerbread costume you also found
out Roker as mr. T there is as Oprah and
as Robin of Batman and Robin what is
your height 60 celebrity crush Margot
Robbie the blonde and we'll get Wall
Street yeah excuse me excuse us back up
I need to fire three people please
identify the ones to fire Jordan slansky
you're kidding every place is picky
dirty nasty do you think you'd be able
to carry me out of this building I think
so yeah I think so sack of potatoes over
the shoulder sure why potatoes cuz I'm
Irish just it's the common phrase
potatoes yeah
Irish guy just a bunch of potatoes right
produced some taters this is the
Irishman is that all I am to you no okay
I mean it could be sick of anything sack
of [ __ ] maybe really I mean [ __ ] is
something so yeah what you just caught
me aside to [ __ ] to my face
problem do you want to be fired no I'm
not gonna fire you I'm not gonna fire
you at all you see here at Kona Co we
believe that everybody makes mistakes
everybody has those days this is
actually a song why they Hannah Montana
Montana song chair chair yeah
Kent I know you because I see you every
day you'll hold cue cards on the show
Kurt you seem nervous
oh no okay
you also seem you seem high quite high
I'm not okay you're not now no yeah I'd
like you to go through okay pick three
people who should be fired immediately
can you even see right now or is it yeah
they got do it on that slant be fired
unbelievable how many years if you
worked for me going on like five and a
half five and a half yeah have you
noticed me aging in the time that you've
been working no you look good you don't
really age that much during young shape
you work out a lot I do work out a lot
but admit it it's like watching a melon
rotten the Sun I mean just say it just
say sometimes I look at you and your
melons Roenick it's okay to say that you
can say it say it say sometimes I look
at you and your face is getting really
old and your melons rotting just say you
look like a rotten knowing what's the
big deal just saying I can't just say it
but wait am I looking around knowing you
look like a rotten melon
you're fired
Oh Jordan
given that everybody without fail that
I've talked of today has said fire
jordan shlonsky I think it's fair for me
to ask you why are you crucial to the
functioning of come to go go it's any
producer's job to make sure the hosts
like yourself is freed up to deal with
creative issues and doesn't have to get
bogged down in the mire of production
difficulties if I do my job well you'll
never know about it so when you're
performing at your highest capacity I
don't notice you is how you're saying it
but also if you weren't here and you
were doing nothing I wouldn't never see
you so how do I know the difference
between you and forming at the highest
level and you don't know nothing they
both feel the same correct possibly I
have decided not to fire you
congratulations thank you in fact I'm so
taken with the general way in which you
conduct your life I decided to reward
you
I now would like you to take charge of
the Konan fire st doll just he can
handle it
I'm trained in cardiopulmonary
resuscitation there's more life in his
eyes miss Alyssa
[Music]
[Applause]